[Musique]
ils s'appelaient Jean Marius Louis ou
encore Pierre Marie et ont participé à
la grande guerre 19 cléciens ont perdu
la vie dans le conflit l'association
villeprosienne CGV retrace leur histoire
de poilu dans une exposition au clés
sousbois une histoire oubli pour
certains nous avons cherché la la
transcription des actes de décès de tous
ces poilus nous avons parcouru les
registres paroissiaux et à ce titre on a
découvert quatre soldats qui sont donc
derrière moi ils sont mis à
l'honneur puisqu'ils ont été oubliés sur
le monument au mort qui a été fait juste
après la guerre en
1921 alors que sur le livre d'or établi
en 1930 il figure bien ils étaient tous
quasiment agriculteurs et ils ont ils
ont vécu la vie de tous les poilus euh
de France et et d'ailleurs desécléciens
des Français ont combattu mais pas
seulement parmi les troupes des soldats
issus des colonies de l'Hexagone leur
nombre réel est discuté par les
historiens l'exposition ensemble
présente la place qu'ils occupaient dans
les rangs français on parle souvent des
poilus on a parlé aussi un petit peu des
tirailleurs sénégalais qu'on appelle
tirailleurs sénégalais mais qui
regroupaient en fait tous les combattant
de l'Afrique noire voilà mais il faut
associer bien sûr les oouaves du Maghreb
tous les combattants asiatiques qui ont
été aussi beaucoup utilisés pour
construire nos routes nos chemins de fer
voilà qui ont été aussi utilisés sur le
front beaucoup de choses ont été dites
comme le fait que ces armées coloniales
ces combattants en particulier des
tirailleurs avaient é utilisé comme de
la chair à canon mais ce qui n'est pas
le cas maintenant les historiens ont
vraiment des documents qui prouvent que
ces combattants ont été associés au
poilu et de manière égale pour la
plupart plus d'un million de militaires
sont morts pour la France lors de la
première guerre mondiale cette année
marque le centenaire de la bataille de
Verdin les expositions sont à découvrir
jusqu'au 20
[Musique]
novembre